(musique abénakise)
- J'ai toujours été consciente
de mon identité autochtone.
- Je suis fier que quelqu'un
d'Abénakis ait p r r rendre à
ce niveau-là.
(applaudissements)
- Michelle O'Bonsawin est
une Abénakise. C'est dans cette
langue qu'elle s'est présentée à
la Chambre des communes.
♪ ♪ ♪
Odanak, c'est le village
d'origine des O'Bonsawin,
sur le bord de la èèère
Saint-François, au Québec.
L'arrière grand-père de la juge
avait quitté sa famille pour
aller travailler dans une mine,
près de Sudbury.
MICHELLE O'BONSAWIN, juge à
la cour suprême du Canada
- Mon père m'a raconté que
lorsqu'il était enfant,
les autres riaient souvent de
lui et de sa famille puis
ils l'appelaient le "petit
sauvage" de la rue Suny Bray.
- La juge se définit aussi comme
franco-ontarienne.
- Je me suis fait dire que comme
petite fopopophone du nord de
l'Ontario, la carrière d'avocate
n'était peut-être vraiment pas
pour moi. Je me suis dit : Ah
ouin, regardez-moi bien allez!
(vrombissement)
- Les deux petits cousins
partagent une passion :
les voitures anciennes.
Et ils ont un combat en commun :
la sauvegarde de la culture.
- Daniel Nolett a rencontré
l'avocate dans les cours de
langue abénakise, qu'ils suivent
ensemble.
Il s s sont plus qu'une douzaine
à la parler.
- Pour quelqu'un que ça fait
Ils ne sont plus qu'une douzaine
à la parler.
- Pourlqlqlqu'un que ça fait
juste quelques années
qu'elle l'apprend, est très
bonne, très très bonne, oui.
Elle est gênée là, mais elle a
une très belle prononciation,
puis elle a une bonne ba
d'un nouveau vocabulaire.
- À peine une douzaine de
personnes parlent encore un peu
l'abénakis. Pourquoi apprendre
une langue pueueue morte?
- Par nos traits, on peut se
confondre très facilement
aujourd'hui dans la communauté
québécoise, mais ce qui nous
distingue, c'est cette
- Michelle O'Bonsawin est
devenue une experte du droit en
santé mentale et des principes
de l'arrêt Gladue, un jugement
historique de la Cour suprême.
Depuis 1999, les juges doivent
considérer, dans leurs
décisions, les circonstances
uniques des premières nations,
leurs blessures, leur passé de
peuples colonisés.
Ce professeur de droit a dirigé
la thèse de la juge O'Bonsawin.
Qui a terminé son doctorat touta
Cour supérieure de l'Ontario. Il
estime que son ancienne
étudiante apportera une
expertise unique, à la cour
suprême.
-  La présence de Michelle avec
une expertise en tradition
juququque autochtone et une
expérience vécue et des
recherches sur la
surreprésentation des
autochtones dans les différents
systèmes de justice, ça change
un peu la conversation.
- Le professeur a été
impressionné par la capacité de
travail de la juge O'Bonsawin et
ses qualités humaines, sa
asasassion